mon entreprise non c'est une entreprise
familiale
donc l'art en boulangerie pâtisserie
où nous sommes une famille à travailler
de 5h du matin à 20h30 21h le soir lié à
moi mon mari ma maman papa
jeu pourquoi enfin de cette entreprise
pourquoi elle a été créée il n'existait
pas de boulangerie et de pâtisserie à
duparc j'ai toujours aimé cuisiner
faire des gâteaux etc cette opportunité
dans un nouveau marché qui se
présentaient à nous et c'est la passion
de partager ce qu'on aime en fait le
pain à la bonne cuisine
c'était le savant mélange qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a ouvert cette
entreprise de façon très générale la
réussite et le succès d'une entreprise
c'est sa force humaine on a trois
boulangers 4 avec mon mari trois ans
deux mois et non papa on est neuf parce
qu'il ya encore quelqu'un qui s'occupe
de tout ce que les livraisons et cetera
et cetera
j'ai vraiment appris le métier sur le
tas
c'est un travail de passion et sans
passion il est impossible de faire du
groupe à
oui tout le mérite de gagner car avec
peu d'expérience au départ nous sommes
capables aujourd'hui de sortir des
produits de qualité
alors avant de commencer à la
boulangerie je me destinais à
l'enseignement
de biette
professeur d'anglais et puis j'ai trouvé
l'atmosphère boucle piqué puis de deux
commerçants
il y avait une liberté qui me manquait
et le goût prononcé de l'entrepreneuriat
a fait qu'aujourd'hui je me suis lancé
dans le voilier de du commerce avec cet
agrément est difficile sauf à ça c'est à
vous aujourd'hui encore de créer donc je
dirais que j'ai trouvé ma voie
je suis sur mon mari a eu cette idée
d'ouvrir une boulangerie a dû par là il
a fait fermer cette idée dans la tête de
ba toons qui petit à petit a été
réceptif mais après
sérieusement c'est
le challenge des créateurs c'est
vraiment la preuve qu' ils se sont
investis pour quelque chose qui a été
reconnue nous ne pouvons qu être fier de
cette victoire
c'est moi qui en ai énormément de zara
partout au sein d' entre la réunion jean
mais ça c'est un rêve mais déjà déjà
consolider les bases
ennemies de choses qu'on pourrait mettre
en place et que j'ai envie de mettre en
place j'espère que nous public et criant
vous à faire c'est loin du changement
qu'on est déjà en train d'apporter
participer au prix du public voter pour
votre candidat favori jusqu'au 27
novembre sur www.cc nav cette carte
point fr et la page facebook challenge
des créateurs